the blunt reality of the world as well
last year geopolitics intruding on the
economics and Marcus mark fob are
familiar with a known unknowns mark
fabra joining us from Zurich this
morning marked so much of what you
predicted it has come true but there is
an inherent resiliency to America why
does America prosper given this great
distortion well thank you for having me
on your program and I wouldn't call
America prospering what is prospering is
the US dollar and US financial assets
but say the economy of the lower classes
the lower income recipients is not doing
particularly well so it's all relative
but relatively speaking i agree with you
whereby have to say in asia we have
still numerous countries that are
growing at say three four percent some
like india six percent per annum so
hello well mark you know I look at where
we are right now within this great
distortion in the way markets move what
action would you like to see out of
Janet Yellen well basically I think that
it would be better if interest rates
were higher I mean I've been in this
business for 40 years I started to work
in 1970 and I really never dreamt that
in Switzerland ten years government
bonds would go to a negative yield in
other words if you buy a 10 years a us a
Swiss franc government bond the yield
will be negative every year for 10 years
mark if it's all gloom and doom out
there where do you go for safety right
now well I think there is in my opinion
one asset class that is inexpensive it
has actually done reasonably well over
the last 12 months
and that is gold and I think that gold
shares have bottomed out between the
october november lows and the recent I
some gold shares were up forty percent
so this is a sector I like unlike other
strategies who say the Americans is the
only game in town I would look at some
emerging economies